I think that will and I should be the
only ones to go outside for a while
we don't know what made Stanley sick you
know anything nobody touched him so I
think we're fine right
positive you just open the door right
you don't go in I didn't touch the door
you know what
it was already open what the door was
already open when he got there yeah
then who opened it
[Music]
[Music]
if you're lying I will kill you
[Music]
we we don't have to worry about nothing
cuz we got the fire and we're burning
one hell of a something they're gonna
sue some matter space I'm really sorry
about pod it's nothing serious
no it is like well this does it thank
you ma'am race human race where did you
two come they don't know what they
[Music]
giving love to how did his father died a
surgeon never kills a patient an
anesthesiologist into the patient but a
surgeon Erica don't be scared now we'll
see you won't be able to move either to
get used to where she what's the Deuter
[Music]
I don't understand why I should have to
pay the Christ my my children should
have to pay the price
but the only thing I can think of that's
close to justice so they can put it out
there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people to see if we
could become something more so when they
needed us we could fight the battles
that they never could
[Music]
in time you will know what it's like to
lose feel so desperately that you're
right
yet to fail all the same
read it
run from it Dustin's still alive
[Music]
evacuate the city
engage your defenses
and get this man a sheet
[Music]
[Music]
fun isn't something one considers
imbalancing universe
but this does put a smile on my face
[Music]
[Music]
the hell are you guys how would you
define terrorism the current definition
is any individual or group it uses
violence to achieve a political goal
administration believes that the drug
cartels fit that definition
[Music]
you want to see this thing through
I'm gonna have to get dirty turning in
this whole dose new rules this time
[Music]
[Music]
help us start a war with hope
[Music]
everyone there you go
she's already captain thanks
[Music]
there is not like people tired disappear
six times the national average
that's just gross I saw something there
is this
yeah I saw - it's all connected by the
sewers as far it lives
[Music]
oh if you'll come with me don't float
too
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
breathe
[Music]
just
[Music]
reach out
[Music]
like
[Music]
darkness
the balance
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I only know one truth
it's time for the Jedi to end
[Music]
what has happened is a colossal military
disaster
[Music]
should go on to the end
we shall never surrender the call went
out we have to go to Dunkirk ready on
the stern line we do it you know where
we're going into war George I'll be
useful sir
you saw me
they need to send more ships every
enemies closer
we've activated the civilian boots
syphilis when they destroy it
where we're going Dunkirk
I'm not going back
your weekend Salus not a bloody Navy
should be at home
there's no hiding from this son we have
a job to do
you're fighting beaches
for fight on the landing grounds
we never surrender
wait a bloody airport
I live here in Columbus Ohio in 2045
it's still ranked the fastest growing
city on earth but it sure doesn't seem
like it when you live in the stacks
they called our generation than missing
millions
missing not because we went anywhere
there's no more left to go
nowhere except the Oasis
it's the only place that feels like I
mean anything
the world where the limits of reality
are your own imagination
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so you me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
very something what do you know about
Canada is the third world country
textiles Shepherds cool outfits all
front explores has searched though it
called it El Dorado
thank for it in South America I'm the
only one you seen it and made that life
[Music]
is
we'll only be the contact
[Music]
you are a good man
good heart
and it's hard for a good level to be a
king
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
they'll I know what you're thinking
how did this happen
well it's a long story
[Music]
Bhaskar is dead
[Music]
[Music]
what have you brought today tell me
[Music]
it's main event time
[Music]
[Applause]
we know each other he's a friend from
work
[Music]
[Music]